字幕: Mai Tanimura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん 聞こえますか？
（笑）
すごい うちわを持って
下さっている方もいますよね
はい では始めたいと思います
皆さんは 私たちが生きる時代というものを
考えたことがあるでしょうか？
私たちは 企画や組織を立ち上げることの
ハードルが低くなった時代に
生きていると思います
ただその代わりに 継続することが難しく
いつのまにか終わってしまったり
はたまた 悲しい終わりを迎える
ということも多いのではないでしょうか？
２つ 皆さんに聞きたいことがあるので
該当するなと思う方は 手を挙げて下さい
１つ目は 企画や組織を 一度でも良いので
立ち上げたことがあるよという方
始めたことがあるという方
手を挙げて下さい
ちょっと 周りを
見ていただくと分かるんですが
約８〜９割ぐらいの方が
手を挙げていると思います
ありがとうございます
そしてもう１つ
企画や組織から離れたり終わるときに
100％ポジティブに
終わりを迎えたことがあるという方
手を挙げてみて下さい
もう一度 ちょっと
周りを見てみて下さいね
今 １割 もしくは２割の方しか
手を挙げていません
ありがとうございます
実は 私は この同じ質問を
Twitterのフォロワーの方や
友人たちにも聞いてみたんですが
やはり１つ目は
９割から８割ぐらいの人が
「立ち上げたことがあるよ」
と手を挙げたんですが
２割以下ぐらいの人が
「100％ポジティブに終わりを
迎えたことがある」という結論に至りました
実際に私はどうかというと
見ていただければ分かるのですが
23歳の頃に立ち上げ 30歳になる
今まで運営してきた非営利団体を
「閉じる」ということを 最近決断しました
20代のほとんどを
この団体に費やしてきたので
ちょっと 言ってみると
普通の女の子に戻る
アイドルのような気分でいます
（笑）
あ 良い感じの苦笑をありがとうございます
ちなみに皆さんは 私たちのように
この「どのように終えるか」という
話し合いをした経験はありますか？
さっきのアイドルを事例に出すと
大体 アイドルも
ファンがつかなかったり共感を得られず
いつの間にか 消えて
しまっている人がいたりだとか
時に女優になったり 企業家になったりとか
ポジティブに転身をしてそうに見えますが
そのほとんどは自分の意思に反して
自分のチームのリーダーや
組織の代表が辞めたり
離れることを決断していることが
多いのではないでしょうか？
そして果たして それらの中に
100％ポジティブかつ社会的にも有益な
終わりがあったと言えるでしょうか？
私たちは
始めるときには すごくパワーを割いて
華々しくスタートするんですが
いつの間にか終わってしまったり
そして戦略的に終えるということが
できずにいる人たち
そして 団体が多くいると思います
なぜなら 私たちは
この「終わる」ということを
どこか悲しい感じがしてしまったり
ネガティブなイメージだったりして
考えることや話し合うことを
避けてきたのではないでしょうか？
でも本当に 終わることは
悲しいことでしょうか？
そして ネガティブにしか
なりえないことなんでしょうか？
私が運営してきた非営利団体の
どのように終えるかという話し合いは
もともとの目的を達成するために
どのようにその目的を達成するのか
そしてどうやったら実現できるのかという
前向きかつポジティブな
話し合いの中で出た結論であり
今回のTEDxのテーマである
「Doscover」したアイデアです
それがこちら
「有機的解散と発展的伝承」です
これは 私のような社会企業家だけでなく
先ほど手を挙げた皆さん
そして これからの時代に
何か残しておきたい人たちにとって
有益なアイデアであると言えると思います
インターネット
私たちはこのインターネットで
様々なもののハードルを下げてきました
例えば 何かものを作ったときには
店舗を設定してものを売らなければ
ならなさそうだった時代だったりだとか
趣味は趣味のまま留め
起業するにも 社会人経験が
ある程度ないと駄目そうだったりとか
情報もどこにあるか分からなくて
どうしたらいいか分からないという理由で
チャレンジできない人が
多くいた時代があったと思います
ただ 今 私たちが生きる時代は
店舗なんて持たなくとも
オンラインからスタートすれば良いし
趣味も Youtubeだったり
Facebookとか Twitterで
言葉に表すことで お金を
儲けられる時代になってきたり
私たちの友達でも
中高生で起業する子たちなんて
山のようにいて
社会人経験なんて 一切ない子たちでも
起業できるようになってきました
そして 大体の情報は
ググればすぐ出てくるし
Facebookに「こんな情報知ってる？」
ってポストすれば
多くの人達 友達たちが
「あぁ それは知ってるよここに載ってるよ」
と教えてくれる
そんなやりとりができるような時代に
生きていると思います
そして 私の運営してきた団体は
どうかというと
私たちのメンバーなんですが —
全国累計130名のメンバーが
滞在しているんですが
本当に 今まで会ったことのない子たちから
SNSを通して この団体に
入りたいと手を挙げてくれて
面談もすべてオンラインで完結し
すべてのミーティングや議事録 メモは
オンライン ネット上にアップすることで
誰でもどこからでも
アクセスできるようにすることによって
初期費用 初めに必要なお金だったり
経験が要らないまま
チャレンジできるようになりました
そして これがまぁ
インターネットが作った
ハードルが下がった時期に
立ち上げた組織の在り方だったり
こういうパターンもあるかなと思うんですが
時として 私は 起業してから６年間の中で
諸先輩方から
「いやいや そんなに簡単に
立ち上げたって成功するわけがない
成果が上がるわけがないよ」
と言われてきたので
いやいや それでも[成果が]上がる時代は
来ているなと思ったからこそ
少しちょっと事例と言うか —
私たちの成果をお伝えしたいと思います
私は 23歳の頃に立ち上げ
30歳になる今まで運営してきて
約６年間活動してきたんですが
ここにある通り
20以上の商品を開発してきたりだとか
80社以上の企業・行政・学校と連携し
さらにはその商品であったり
自分たちが企画したものが
70市町村以上に広まりました
そして この考え方や在り方を参考にしたいと
アジア・太平洋９カ国の
リーダーたちが来日してきてくれ
私たちに「どうしたら良いか？」と
質問に来てくれるほどにもなりました
これが私たちの
様々なもののハードルが下がった時代の
在り方なのではないでしょうか？
ただ 一方で 皆さんに
お伝えしなければならないのは
ポジティブなことばかりでは
ないということです
地方の人が来ない観光地であったりだとか
担い手のいない伝統文化
はたまた 入社希望者のいない
中小企業もそうだと思います
立ち上げたは良いものの
継続することが難しく
そして 「終わる」という選択を
採り切れていない所が山ほどあるということを
皆さんも分かってきている
のではないかなと思います
実際に先ほど 自治体とお仕事を
させて頂いているということを
ちょっとお伝えしたんですが
多くの自治体から似たようなことを
私 言われていまして
その言葉もちょっと 皆さんに
バラしちゃいたいなと思うんですが
それが こちらです
読み上げますね
「移住・定住してほしい」
「観光客 増やしたい」
「地域のリソースを活用してほしい」
「伝統文化を継承したい」
「地域の良いところをPRしてほしい」
こんなに思いの詰まった方々に
一市町村だけでなく
本当にたくさんの自治体の方々に
このような質問と依頼をされてきました
もちろん 尊くて素晴らしいなと思うんですが
よーく見てもらうと分かるんですが
やっぱり この背景には
「継続すること 発展することこそが
素晴らしい」という
概念や思い込みが
見え隠れするなと思いませんか？
私は 継続すること 発展することは
あくまで 選択肢の一つであるべきで
そこが本質なのではないと思います
私たちは この 継続し 発展したその先に
何を成し遂げたいかとか 何を実現したいかが
本質なのではないでしょうか？
そこがすれ違っている —
継続することが
目的になってしまっているような
組織やプロジェクトが
山のようにあるように感じました
ここで少し —
半分くらいの方が 今日は
学生さんだと聞いているので —
今はちょっと 企業や自治体の
話が多くなってしまったので
ライフスタイルというか
日常生活の中でもこういうことが
起こり得るということを紹介します
完全なる独断と偏見で トップ３を決めました
始めたは良いものの
継続も終わるのも難しいトップ３！
（拍手）（笑）
ありがとうございます
ちょっと無理矢理感 ありましたね
（笑）
完全なる独断と偏見なんですが
１位 習い事
２位 恋愛
３位 ダイエット
本当に皆さん 頷いていたり
笑っている方は 要注意ですからね
（笑）
始めたは良いものの やっぱり継続は難しくて
しかも終わるときに —
例えば 皆さん 恋愛を経験したことが
ある方は多いと思うんですけど —
やっぱり 終わるときに
自然消滅をしてしまったり
ポジティブにお別れする
なんてことはありましたか？
やはり 立ち上げたは良いものの
継続が難しく終わるのが難しいことは
日常生活の中でもたくさんあります
ただ 私は どんなことがあっても
時代や 環境や 他人のせいにしない
と決めています
これまで出した事例すべてが
どこか時代や環境や他人のせいにして
「自分たちは頑張っているんだ」 としている
目線だったりだとか
言い方が多かったなと私は思いました
なので私は いやいやそうじゃなくて
自分たちがもともと立ち上げたときの
目的に対する責任感だったり
どうしてそこまで達成したいのか
実現したいのかという思いの違いが
ここに出ているのではないかと思います
ここで皆さんの中で少しずつ
「終わり方」とか「終わること」に
興味が出始めたかなと
ちょっと 目線とかうなずき具合で感じたので
ここで終わり方のパターンを
ご紹介したいと思います
こちら —
スタンフォードソーシャル
イノベーションレビューで出している
「組織の終わり方」のグラフになります
左から 初めスタートして
継続・発展して行った この青のラインが
終わり方のパターンに当たるんですが
上から 一番上が継続・発展という意味で
今までの事例を出したものが
求めていた「継続すること・
発展すること」なんですが
他にも自治体に受け渡したり
企業に買収させるというやり方があったり
「オープンソース」という
誰でもアクセスでき 可変できるようにする
という手法もあれば
この一番下の「もともとの目的を達成する」
という終わり方もあります
ただ 私 ６年間 起業をして
いろんな企業家だったりだとか
プロジェクトや企画を見てきたんですが
それでも この選択を
考えている組織はごくわずかで
さらには 選択に至る前に
自然消滅してしまったり
がむしゃらに続けることだけを考えて
もともとの目的を忘れてしまっている組織が
多かったなと思います
そこで 私たちは じゃあ
いくつかのパターンを試してみようと
私の組織でも 終わり方のパターン
試してみたんですが
どれもしっくりこなかったんですね
なので私たちは
「自分らしい終わり方とは何ぞや？」
どう組織を終わるべきか どうあるべきか と
話し合いの中で出たアイデアが
「有機的解散と発展的伝承」です
これは 1864年にハーバード・スペンサー
という方が作った造語
「survival of the fittest」—
日本語で言うと「適者生存」
という考え方があります
聞いたことがある方も
いらっしゃるかなと思うんですが
「変化していく流れの中で
適した者が残っていく」という考え方です
この考えを用いて 私たちは今まで
「What we want to do」—
「私たちがどうありたいか 」とか
「何を成し遂げたいか」という主体を
自分たちに持ってきたんですが
いやいや 私たちは大きな流れの
一部であるんだと捉えたときに
この大きな流れ
「What we want our world to be」—
「私たちはどんな世界を実現したいのか？」
「どんな未来を実現したいのか」という中で
「じゃあ 私たちは
どうあるべきなのか？」という
言わば 東洋の一元論のような
考え方を持つようになり
視野・視座を高め
自分たちがどうあるべきかを考えました
そうしたときに より良い世の中だったり
実現したいことを考えたとき
私たちだけじゃなくて
独りが頑張る —
100％ポジティブな人たちが
１つだけあるんじゃなくて
より多くのチャレンジャーが
増えていった方が
この大きな流れを作り出し
実現できるのではないか
そして加速できるのではないかと考えました
そこで私たちは この６年間培った
知識や資金・情報・人脈を
すべてをわかりやすくまとめ
継承する相手を公募し 引き継ぎ
私たちは立ち去る ということを決断しました
もちろんここに居続けるということも
選択肢としてあったんですが
やはり私たちがいることによって
この流れのボトルネックになってしまったり
私たちがこの流れを[減]速させてしまう
のではないかと思ったので
私たちが 抜けることによって
この作りたい未来を実現する
ということを決断しています
今までであればネガティブな 解散は
目的達成のための解散へ
そして 目的のない伝承は
時代・業界を加速するための伝承へ
私たちはそのために
「有機的解散と発展的伝承」という
今までにはあまりなかった
解散・終わり方を
実現したいと思っています
言わば もともと同じ種を持ち
飛び立つタンポポの綿毛のように
そして 同じ星だったのが 宇宙で爆発し
たくさんの星になって輝く宇宙のように
私たちはこれを実現したいと思っています
皆さんは 皆さんの関わる組織や
プロジェクトをどのように終えますか？
そして 皆さんは
これからの変化しゆく時代に
何を残していきたいですか？
(拍手)